three hi I'm Ann veneman I'm the
executive director of UNICEF one of the
issues we've been talking about here at
the World Economic Forum is the issue of
Haiti and the devastation from the
earthquake of course is the United
Nations children children's agency we
are most concerned about the plight of
children how does how do children get
back into school for example only fifty
percent of the children we're going to
school before the earthquake one of the
one of the things in the process of
rebuilding the country not only has to
be the investment of businesses here
those businesses who are committing here
in Davos but also to rebuild education
systems health care systems make sure
that the children of haiti are protected